in the lobby of Ramsey solutions receipt
it is with us
I receded how are you I'm good how are
you better than I deserve
so what's the derivation of this name ah
nigeria nigerian okay very cool well I
knew it wasn't a lower Alabama that's
all I knew
okay cool well welcome it's good to have
you so you're here from where I'm here
from Atlanta Georgia very cool and here
to do your debt-free screen
I certainly am congratulations how much
have you paid off I love it
how long did that take you 30 months
good for you and range of income during
that time I started at about 56 and it
increased about 68 good for you what do
you do for a living
okay the easy version does not work with
me you work with what patterns yes I
work for a fashion company okay so my
tech designer Oh me yes very cool
okay well neat that's fun so what kind
of debt was the seventy thousand most of
it was a car that I had just bought on
stupid tax and the other thirty was
student loans
you bought an expensive car I did I
bought a mini and I decked it out I love
it you did very cool so you're single I
am single decked out mini is 40 grand
I mean you decked it and then it had its
own deck on top I mean wow oh no getting
rid of the mistake I mean the are so
tell me your story what happened thirty
months ago that said she won't fire cuz
you've been going kiddo
yes so really it started I said I was
gonna pay my debt off by the time I was
thirty and thirty came around and I was
like oh I'm not very close to this and I
was at church and they passed her book
out and that was like the plan
yeah there's the plan and now I have the
planet so really get it done and so from
there I'm either a zero to a hundred
anyway so gazelle intense and I took
your class and it was like yeah let's
run we're gonna do this we're gonna get
it done so you went to financial base
university at your church yeah so
actually I got the book first and then
I'm a super super super nerd I took the
class after I got the book and then I
gave the book to everybody else thank
you thank you very much
very cool well you've this is an amazing
accomplishment so you sold the car in
the car sold for how much the car sold
for about twenty nine so I use cash
float about 41 then mm-hmm that's
impressive yeah good for you Thanks very
cool so did you have support from family
yes yes I did um I mean emotional
support I think most people were a
little surprised that what I was
planning to do again culturally there's
not a lot of people who believe they can
be completely debt free but I think most
of my friends and family realized that
once I put my mind to something that's
it you might as well get out the way
unless you want to get run over and no
stopping this one yeah run over you with
my mini wrap for us really good for you
very cool very cool so what do you tell
people when they ask how did you pay off
$70,000 in debt what is the key to
getting out of debt buckling down in any
way possible I mean I was living by
myself I got two additional roommates I
had a part-time job I stopped going out
to eat
I started meal planning like literally
everything that I could do to put every
single penny I had on this debt to get
it done is what I did so your
personality style is is that when you go
you go all-in you mentioned that a
couple of times I try to get people to
do that even if it's not their
personality style because they have the
best results that when you're committed
I mean when you decide to do something
you change everything yes it changes
everything everything and you decided I
mean because you don't care what other
people think once you decide yeah
and that's a you know there I think the
tremendous focus you have displayed
unbelievable focus as part of the reason
you've got the unbelievable results as
fast as you did it is you know people
kind of play around they go well I do a
little you know but it doesn't work when
you do that you got to get all in yeah
yeah and when you do that at rocks I'm
so proud of you congratulations yeah
very very well done and so what was the
extra job you took I was working on a
banana republic visual merchandising in
the evenings and weekends and actually
most times it was 5:00 a.m. before I
went to work or whenever I took vacation
from my full-time job I wasn't doing
this job yeah okay so what were you know
and you're uniquely qualified to help
banana yes right with the merchandise
very cool good for you very fun well
what's the hardest part of this for you
once so at the beginning once I got the
smaller that's paid off in the car paid
once I got to the student loan I'm
continuing to be gizelle intense when it
just felt like it was going to go on for
a while and not having no small
successes so it was a lot of leaning in
and just it's gonna get done one foot in
front of the other
yeah it's like an a weight-loss plan
when you when you plateau yeah right
before you drop off again but you just
you can't quit you gotta file through
yeah that's very good very cool
well congratulations I'm proud of you
very very well done we're gonna give you
a copy of Chris Hogan's book signed by
him it's a number one bestseller it's
called retire inspired because that's
your next step yeah is to build wealth
and continue to live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else however you can let up a little now
yes now that you hit this point we can
go back to having a little bit of a life
and actually doing some things and
enjoying the fact that you know your
freak yeah you've fought so hard to be
free yes very cool very proud of it my
next step is a little more extreme
though what's that I'm going on a
year-long mission trip to 11 countries
over 11 months well why not I know right
yeah know that now no girls no save up
the money to do it yeah well actually
it's a lot of fun or anything
preparation and so I've been buying gear
I leave on October 1st
so yes it's it's soon so I ain't gear
what's the first two countries the first
year Malaysia and Thailand okay are you
going to Nigeria as part of it I'm not
I'm going to zambia zimbabwe malawi okay
all around it but not there yeah and
that's your family heritage or you were
born there I was born here in America
but my father is Nigerian he's your
heritage Wow well congratulations this
is awesome Enki and so living like no
one else and now you're able to give
like no one else an 11-month mission
trip yeah good for you I'm very very
proud of you wow that is just awesome
this is why we do what we do is people
like you very good very well done all
right
it's receipted she's from Atlanta
Georgia at least for now I'm making 70
thousand bucks a year thirty are paid
off 70,000 bucks making 68 did it in 30
months and sold the mini baby but she's
gonna travel the world right now for
Jesus I'm so proud of you count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
why
oh that is how it's done if you go
fingers go home man this is how you do
it right here well done and you know you
just it's hard to halfway do stuff if
you want something done you got to just
go all-in
I mean you can't just sorta be there I
mean we you know nobody likes people
that are sort of there have you noticed
that people there are football fans only
when the team is winning you know nobody
wants a what we call them fair-weather
fans like yeah like jesus said lukewarm
yeah right I mean nobody likes that
but people like Rasheed it man that kid
right there she'd do anything there is
no stopping that one I'm serious I know
what she said and I heard her don't get
in her way there'll be a body in the
road he's going places man hey why not
you why not you maybe you should be an
expert on something other than the
Bachelorette maybe you should read
something maybe you should decide today
you're going to do something amazing
with your finances or your marriage or
your kids or your physical condition
it's up to you you know all those people
running those conventions those
politician people none of them gonna
come to your house and fix your life dog
you get to do it so take a lesson from
that young lady she took control of her
destiny man see he is what makes this
country great so proud of her very very
well done this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a $500,000 in the car
you